THIS IS "THE FIVE"."
FOX NEWS ALERT, PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS SET TO HOLD A NEWS CONFERENCE
IN MINUTES AND WE WILL BRING YOU
THERE LIVE WHEN IT HAPPENS.
PRESIDENT COULD ADDRESS A
POLITICAL FIRESTORM HE IGNITED
THIS MORNING WHEN HE ASKED IF
THE ELECTION DATE SHOULD BE
CHANGED OVER CONCERNS ABOUT MAIL
AND VOTER FRAUD.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETING JUST A
FEW MINUTES AGO, I’M GLAD I WAS
ABLE TO GET THE VERY DISHONEST
LAME STREAM MEDIA TO FINALLY
START TALKING ABOUT THE RISKS TO
OUR DEMOCRACY FROM DANGEROUS
UNIVERSAL MEAL AND VOTING.
NOT ABSENTEE VOTING WHICH I
TOTALLY SUPPORT.
HE ADDED THAT AMERICANS SHOULD
KNOW THE RESULTS OF THE ELECTION
THE NIGHT OF.
THEY ARE FURIOUS CALLING THE
PRESIDENT DICTATOR SAYING HIS
COMMENTS ARE MEANT TO BE A BIG
DISTRACTION.
AND BARACK OBAMA GOING AFTER
TRUMP FOR THE FUNERAL OF
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS.
>> THOSE IN POWER WHO ARE DOING
THEIR DARNDEST TO DISCOURAGE
PEOPLE FROM VOTING BY CLOSING
POLLING LOCATIONS AND TARGETING
MINORITIES AND ATTACKING OUR
VOTING RIGHTS WITH SURGICAL
PRECISION, EVEN UNDERMINING THE
POSTAL SERVICE IN THE RUN-UP TO
AN ELECTION.
THAT’S GOING TO BE DEPENDED UPON
MAIL-IN BALLOTS SO PEOPLE DON’T
GET SICK.
>> Jesse: WE WILL GET TO
BARACK OBAMA IN A MINUTE.
I ADMIT IT WAS A MISCHIEVOUS
TWEETS, BUT NOW THAT THE
PRESENCE HAS OUR ATTENTION, I
FIND SOMETHING VERY INTERESTING.
NEW JERSEY HAD A SPECIAL
ELECTION LAST MONTH AND IT WAS
ALL MAIL-IN, EVERYBODY DID IT BY
MAIL AND 10% OF THE BALLOTS WERE
REJECTED, DISQUALIFIED, FOR
SIGNATURE ISSUES OR THEY WERE
LATE, MANY, MANY REASONS.
SO IF YOU HAVE TURNOUT IN 2020,
140 MILLION AMERICANS CASTING
THEIR VOTE.
IF 10% OF THOSE MAIL-IN BALLOTS
ARE DISQUALIFIED, THAT’S
14 MILLION AMERICANS ARE
DISENFRANCHISED.
ARE YOU OKAY WITH THAT?
>> Juan: NO, I WOULD LIKE TO
IMPROVE IT BUT THAT’S DIFFERENT
THAN WITH THE PRESIDENT WAS
TALKING ABOUT.
HE WAS SUGGESTING THERE WOULD BE
FRAUD, THERE WOULD BE
CORRUPTION, THAT SOMEHOW THE
CORRUPTION MIGHT BE TILTED ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER AND PEOPLE WHO
WERE ACTING IN SOME CORRUPT
MANNER.
>> Jesse: YOU COULD ASK THE
DEMOCRATS TO DO THAT, THEY
CHEATED IN THE LAST ELECTION.
>> Juan: WHAT?
I DON’T EVEN WANT TO GO THERE.
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP WON IN
2016, BUT THERE IS NO EVIDENCE
OF ANY FRAUD RELATED TO ABSENTEE
VOTING OR MAIL-IN VOTING IN THIS
COUNTRY.
BUT AGAIN, WHAT’S IMPORTANT HERE
AND THIS MIGHT BE PERSUASIVE TO
YOU, IF YOU THINK ABOUT
MARCO RUBIO, TED CRUZ,
MITCH McCONNELL, KEVIN
McCARTHY, THOSE PEOPLE ARE
REPUBLICANS AND TODAY THEY ALL
SAID THIS IS WRONG.
THERE SHOULD BE NO DELAY IN THE
ELECTION OF NOVEMBER 2020.
THAT WAS WHAT THEY SAID AND I
THINK YOU’RE VERY CLEAR.
SO I THINK THIS IS NOT THE
ACTION OF A PARTY, THIS IS THE
ACTION OF ONE MAN WHO KNOWS HE
IS LOSING AND IS WILLING TO
TRASH DEMOCRACY AND TRASH OUR
CONSTITUTION BECAUSE HE’S SO
UPSET.
WHEN JOE BIDEN PREDICTED THIS IN
APRIL, JOE BIDEN SAID TO COME
TRUMP WILL TRY TO DELAY THE
ELECTION.
WHAT WAS THE RESPONSE?
BIDEN IS SPREADING CONSPIRACY
THEORY.
WHILE TRUMP HAS GONE THERE AND
THIS IS WILD.
>> Jesse: NO ONE REALLY
BELIEVES HE WILL DELAY THE
ELECTION.
HOW DO YOU READ THESE TWEETS AND
IF YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON
BARACK OBAMA AT THE FUNERAL FOR
LOUIS, BE MY GUEST.
>> Greg: HOW DARE DONALD TRUMP
UNDERMINE THE POSTAL SERVICE?
HOW DARE HE UNDERMINE THE POSTAL
SERVICE?
TRUMP IS STILL ABLE TO WORK THE
MEDIA OR YEARS INTO THIS WITH
THE TWEETS.
IT’S JUST TOO EASY AND HE’S LIKE
SHARING, AND THE MEDIA IS LIKE
LAMB TOPIC.
REMEMBER THAT VENTRILOQUIST WITH
A LITTLE LAMB CHOP AND MAKES
THEM MOVE AROUND WITH THE
STRINGS?
HERE’S THE THING.
I’M AGAINST IN GENERAL THIS KIND
OF TALK ABOUT IT ELECTION
CORRUPTION WHICH IS WHY WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS STAYED WITH THE
FRAUDULENT STEELE DOSSIER WAS SO
DAMAGING TO THE COUNTRY.
THEY USED A FAKE PAID FOR
FOREIGN INTEL TO CALL 2016 INTO
QUESTION AND THAT WENT ON FOR
THREE YEARS.
FOR YEARS, PROBABLY STILL GOING
ON.
PEOPLE OUTRAGED AT WHAT OTHER
PEOPLE SAID, IT FEELS KIND OF
LIKE A COUP, WELL MAYBE IT FELT
LIKE A COUP WHEN YOU FIND OUT
MORE ABOUT DOSSIER ITSELF.
BUT THE HORSE LEFT THE BARN AND
IT WAS CARRYING PANDORA’S BOX
WITH IT.
THIS IS WHAT THE REAL PROBLEM
ONCE.
ANY CLOSE ELECTION WILL BE SEEN
AS STOLEN, BECAUSE OF THIS,
BECAUSE OF THE DEMOCRATS STATED
IN 2016.
WE ARE NOW IN TROUBLE BECAUSE OF
WHAT THEY DID AND WE KNOW IF JOE
WINS EVEN BY A HAIR OR HAIR
PLUG, TRUMP SUPPORTER’S ARE NOT
GOING TO RIOT.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO RIOT
BECAUSE, A, POLITICS TO THEM IS
IMPERSONAL AND, B, IT’S NOT
PERSONAL.
IF TRUMP WINS BY A HAIR OR MORE,
WHAT YOU WILL SEE, YOU WILL SEE
MORE PORTLAND, YOU WILL HAVE
WHAT THE MEDIA WANTS YOU TO
THINK.
THEY WANT YOU TO THINK THAT THIS
WILL BE TROUBLE, ESSENTIALLY
PSYCHOLOGICALLY EXTORTING YOU TO
VOTE IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE PREPARING
THE GROUNDWORK, KENNEDY, FOR THE
RESULTS OF THE ELECTION.
YOU DON’T KNOW WHO WON IN THE
ELECTION AND YOU HAVE A BUNCH OF
VALID SITTING IN THE BACK ROOM
THAT HAVE BEEN MAILED IN, THERE
COULD BE SOME FUNNY BUSINESS AS
OF SEEN AND OTHER ELECTIONS AND
THAT’S THE DANGEROUS TERRITORY.
>> Kennedy: WELL, JUAN WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
BEING A SORE LOSER AND WE HAD TO
LISTEN TO MISSES, WHAT HAPPENED!
THE RECON TEN CANNOT LET GO AND
SHE WAS A WOMAN WHO CHALLENGED
THEN CANDIDATE TRUMP DURING ONE
OF THE DEBATES TO ACCEPT THE
OUTCOME OF ELECTIONS BECAUSE YOU
KNOW, OUR COUNTRY IS BASED ON
THE DEMOCRACY WHERE WE ACCEPT
WHEN WE LOSE, EXCEPT WHEN SHE
LOSES WHICH IS PHENOMENAL.
THERE IS A SYSTEM OF VOTING THAT
ONLY ONE PARTY IS EXCITED ABOUT
AND THAT ALWAYS MAKES ME A
LITTLE NERVOUS.
I DO LIKE THE IDEA THAT
DIFFERENT COUNTIES AND STATES
CAN HAVE THEIR OWN PREFERRED
FORM OF VOTING AND OREGON IS ALL
MAIL-IN BALLOTS AND THE
PRESIDENT’S ABSENTEE BALLOTS ARE
VERY CRITICAL AND THERE ARE LOTS
OF PEOPLE WHO OPT IN TO A
MAIL-IN BALLOT SYSTEM.
I DON’T TRUST THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SO IF YOU THINK THE
PANDEMIC RESPONSE HAS BEEN BAD
AT, HOW DO YOU THINK THEY ARE
GOING TO DO WITH A MASK MAIL IN
FEDERALLY MANDATED VOTING
SYSTEM?
THEY COULD BE A DISASTER.
>> Jesse: THE DEMOCRATS ARE
TELLING EVERYONE DON’T GO OUT
AND PROTEST.
BUT I LIKE THE IDEA THAT YOU GO
INTO THE VOTING BOOTH AND YOU
ARE THE ONLY ONE THERE WITH YOUR
BALLOT, YOU VOTE FOR WHATEVER
YOU WANT AND THEN IT GETS
COUNTED THERE AT THE POLLING
STATION AND REPORTED THAT NIGHT.
WHEN YOU GET EVERYBODY ELSE
INVOLVED, I DON’T HAVE A GOOD
FEELING ABOUT THAT.
YOU COULD ADDRESS THAT WERE
ADDRESSED BARACK OBAMA.
>> THE VOTING THING I THINK IS
IMPORTANT.
THAT’S IDEAL, BEING ABLE TO GO
TO THE VOTING BOOTH IS IDEAL,
BUT I THINK THAT’S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WOULD BE IMPORTANT
FOR ANYONE INCLUDING THE
PRESIDENT AND IT’S A DEAL IN
REALITY.
THE IDEA IS THAT THERE WILL BE
MANY STATES THAT OFFER UP
MAIL-IN VOTING AND HE’S TRYING
TO MAKE A DISTINCTION ABOUT
ABSENTEE VOTING VERSUS MAIL-IN
VOTING.
IT IS A DISTINCTION WITH THE
DIFFERENCE, BUT WHAT’S HAPPENING
AS MANY STATES INCLUDING
FLORIDA, THE REPUBLICAN PARTY OF
FLORIDA SO WORRIED THAT THERE
MAIL-IN VOTING, THEIR ABSENTEE
VOTING IS SO LOW COMPARED TO THE
DEMOCRATS ALREADY THAT, THE
PRESIDENT IS A VERY PERSUASIVE
TO HIS SUPPORTERS WHO WERE BEING
ASKED ABOUT MAIL-IN VOTING.
LIKE NO THANKS, IT’S FRAUDULENT.
SO HE’S TRYING TO MAKE THAT
DISTINCTION.
EXCEPT FOR MAYBE THE
FOURTH OF JULY, THE PRESIDENT
ACTUALLY FAILS ANY OF THE NEW
CYCLES IN THE MONTH OF JULY.
AND THE PAGEANTRY THERE.
THE NUMBER ONE THING ON PEOPLE’S
MIND RIGHT NOW IS CORONAVIRUS.
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT SCHOOL,
WORRIED ABOUT THEIR HEALTH AND
WORRY ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
THIS ISSUE WITH THE MAIL-IN
VOTING IS WAY DOWN ON THEIR
LIST.
HE’S NOT TALKING ABOUT ANY OF
THOSE THINGS TODAY BUT MAYBE HE
WELL TODAY AT THE PRESS
CONFERENCE.
UPON PRESIDENT OBAMA AND WHETHER
THAT WAS POLITICIZING, YES.
BUT THE FAMILY AND FRIENDS AND
LOVED ONES BELIEVED THAT WHAT’S
ON THE LIST WOULD HAVE WANTED IS
FOR ACTIVISM TO CONTINUE AND I
THINK THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS